I want to pick up where
I left off on Monday.
Speaking about roles is
two principles of justice.
And as you will recall,
I mentioned that roles really changed
the subject with respect to what the
metric of justice is that
rather than focus on utility,
somehow measured or welfare
as it's sometimes called. Um,
instead roles embraces resources.
The idea of focusing on
certain basic resources,
the assumption being that no matter what
your particular goals in life turn out
to be, no matter what your
particular life plan turns out to be.
And those are not things we know because
we're behind the veil of ignorance.
You're going to want more rather
than less in the way of liberties,
more rather than less in the way of
opportunities and more rather than less in
the way of income and wealth.
So I'm thinking I didn't mention that'll
come into play in today's lecture is
that rolls has to of course,
deal with the fact that the moment you
have a theory that affirms more than one
value, you have to think about, well
what happens when the values conflict?
Um,
what if maximizing liberties can only
come at the expense of opportunities or if
you like,
uh,
distributing income and wealth and if
in a way that you regard as fair or just
conflicts with what you say about
the distribution of liberties, uh,
anytime you have more than one value,
you have to deal with the possibility
of the conflict among them.
And he does deal with that. He has, um,
an appeal to what he
calls a lexical ran king,
which is short for the more cumbersome
term lexicographical ranking.
And what that means is that anytime you
want more rather than fewer in the way
of liberties,
you want more in fewer in
the way of opportunities and
you want more than rather
than less than the way of
income and wealth. But in
any time there's a conflict,
something higher in
the electrical ranking,
Trump's what's lower so that if the only
way you could get more rather than less
income and wealth was to compromise
people's liberties, you wouldn't do it.
Okay.
So that's the notion of a lexical ranking.
You want to maximize each,
each item in the lexical ranking subject
to the constraint that it does not come
at the expense of maximizing something
that's higher in that lexical ranking.
Okay.
And then we talked about
his first principle and I
gave you the illustration of
religious freedom as the of thing he's
thinking about when he talks about
distributing all liberties in a way
that gives people the most extensive
possible freedom,
compatible with a like freedom for all.
And this is not to be confused
with the idea of neutrality, right?
We went through that.
Um,
and so we gave the example of whether
to have, if you comparing say,
a fundamentalist regime with a regime
that has a disestablished church.
The reason for preferring the regime with
the disestablished church is that the
most disadvantaged person in
that regime is less, namely,
that say the fundamentalists is less
disadvantaged than the person who does not
affirm the established fundamentalist
regime beliefs of a fundamentalist regime.
So you, you always
compare the least, then.
I know it's a cumbersome way
of putting it, but I, there's
not a, there's not a, uh,
mmm
elegant way of putting it.
But what you want to do is compare that,
the condition of the most adversely
affected person in each situation and say
which, which would you
rather be basically. And
you're going to always pack,
uh,
the one that minimizes the harm
to the least advantage person.
So the justice,
the standpoint of justice is the
standpoint of the least advantaged person.
But this isn't a bleeding hardpoint
but rather a self interested point,
um, because you don't know who you
are behind the veil of ignorance.
Okay.
Um,
no,
let's talk about his second principle,
which is in fact divided
into two principals.
So he really has three principles.
The, the first part of it is for,
he says social and economic inequalities
are to be arranged so that they are
both
attached
two offices and positions open to all
under conditions of fair equality of
opportunity. That is, you'll
see to be, that's not a typo.
I'll come to,
to a,
in a minute for some reason
known only to John Rawls.
Um, he, he put to a before to be,
but he meant to put to be before two a
in the sense that to be his lexicon prior
to two a.
Okay.
So that's what I'm doing to be first
and that to be is what governs the
distribution of opportunities.
And he's essentially saying,
okay,
fair equality of opportunity.
Okay,
what does that mean? It means
no apartheid. It means if you,
for instance,
we ha we still today have a system in
America where occupation by occupation
women earn about 86% of what men
earn in exactly the same occupation.
So there's,
there's gender discrimination
in renumeration for employment.
So we would say,
um,
those systems are illegitimate systems,
which reward women less than
men on a systematic basis are,
wouldn't be chosen.
It's not,
you wouldn't never choose a system that
privileges one gender because you don't
know where they're going to turn
out to be the women or the men.
You would never accept the system of job
reservation such as a park aid because
you don't know whether you're going
to be black or white and not knowing.
Um,
you always look from the standpoint
of the most adversely affected person.
And so you would say,
uh, no to, uh, partake.
You'd say no to a system which
privileges one gender over the other.
Okay.
And then you can see,
I think how the lexical ranking would
come into play because let's suppose you
have,
um,
let's suppose you have a
status quo in which as I said,
women on average earn 86% of what
men earn in the same professions.
And somebody comes along and says,
well,
so we need an affirmative
action program to remedy that.
Then the question would be, okay,
but does the affirmative action program
conflict with any thing protected by the
first principle?
And those opposed to it would say yes.
And those in favor of it would say no.
And that's what you would
be arguing about. Okay.
Because it might be the case that if I'm
the only way in which you could achieve
affirmative action actually interfered
with the liberties protected by the first
principle,
then you would say,
even though it's necessary from the
standpoint of the second principle,
we won't do it. And if you, if
you, uh, if we had more time,
we could have gone into the new haven
firefighters case and maybe we can do some
of this in section that the
Supreme Court dealt with loss, um,
summer,
uh,
where essentially they said some version
of the fact that the affirmative action
program to achieve promotions in the new
haven fire department interfered with
basic freedoms.
Um,
that rolls would of put under the first
principle and of course the other side
made the opposite plane,
but that that is essentially
how it would be argued about.
Um,
so I think that the,
the principle of fair
equality of opportunity is
relatively straight forward and
its own terms. You would, the, the, uh,
animating thought is that not
knowing who you're going to be,
you would never agree to assist them
that systematically this privileges some
group for fear that you're going to
turn out to be in that group. Okay.
Um, so it's relatively straight
forward. But now I want to come to,
to a,
which is probably the argument in
roles as book that's attracted the most
attention and that is that as it,
it's actually third in his lexical
ranking. Um, and that is the,
the claim that income and wealth is to
be distributed to the greatest benefit of
the least advantaged individual to the
greatest benefit of the least advantaged
individual.
This is not a principle
that rolls invented.
It's an old principle of welfare
economics, which used to go under the,
under the label Maxi men,
not Maxine Milam Maxi men,
Max I m I n short for maximize the minimum
share Maxi men maximize the minimum
share. Um, Rawls calls it
the difference principle,
but it's the same idea as maximizing
the minimum share. And th the,
the intuition behind the
difference principle is
exactly the same intuition that
we've been talking about
by reference to the,
the general conception of
distributive justice, um,
which is remember distributed all
goods equally and less than and equal
distribution works to
everybody's advantage.
And you get from everybody's advantage
to focusing on the condition of the worst
off.
Why?
Because of this argument that,
well,
if you're the worst off person
and you can affirm something,
then everybody else
will affirm it as well.
If you'll choose it when you're
the most adversely affected,
you'll also choose it if you're a
second or third or fourth or fifth most
adversely affected person.
Now,
um,
there's actually a complexity when you
start to think about the distribution of
income and wealth that has not come up
in the consideration of the other two
principals,
which I'll just mention and it's then say
a couple of things about and then move
on and we'll come back to it later.
And that is well, but what if,
what if there was a principal that gave
a very small benefit to the person at
the bottom but at a huge
cost to the middle class?
Okay.
Would you,
would you chose it?
Because what are the odds that you're
going to turn out to be the person at the
very bottom?
Okay.
And you would think about
this for a variety of reasons.
It might be a trickle
down argument or you know,
Bentham's claim that the ritual burn
that crops before giving them to the poor
or some other argument.
But if you could achieve a very
minor increments to the condition,
the person at the bottom, at a huge cost
to the middle class would, you would,
you wouldn't necessarily
want to do that.
And so roles has two points
to make about that. Um,
neither of which is entirely satisfying.
The one is his argument
about grave risks and it,
it works like this.
It's the claim that,
well,
one of the things we know,
and this is a perfectly um,
uncontroversial claim,
one of the things we know is that
even when there's moderate scarcity,
that doesn't mean there won't be
some people who are in grave danger.
That is to say there's no necessary
relationship between the level of economic
development in a country and the
distribution of income and well,
so you can have a wealthy country,
but there still can be extremely
poor people in it. Okay. Um,
that's true.
We can have bag ladies living out
of lockers in grand central station,
at least when they used to have
lockers in grand central station,
which they don't anymore. But, uh,
let's not deal with that particular piece.
So there's no necessary relationship
between the level of economic development
and the distribution of income and
wealth in a society. Therefore,
you have to assume, even if, even if
there's relative scarcity,
you might turn out to be
the person who's starving.
You might turn out to be that bag lady.
Okay.
So even if,
and even if the probability
of being that person is low,
the costs of being that person,
that's our high. So, uh,
even if the probability, it's like,
I don't know if you remember the,
the argument, uh, Rumsfeld made, uh,
in his counter terrorism strategy and the,
the so called 1% solution,
uh,
the,
and this was that even if there's a 1%
probability that we're going to be hit by
a certain kind of terrorist attack,
we should treat it as a 100% probability
because the costs of being hated so
high. Um, so the,
the, the probability of the
event may be low, but the,
if you turn out to be that person,
you're going to starve to death.
So we,
it's this as roles as assumption
about grave risks. Okay.
So all of that's plausible enough.
The reason I say it's not entirely
satisfying is if you really took the grave
risks,
ideas seriously,
why in the world would you make
this third in your lexicon ranking?
Because after all,
what good is freedom of speech or freedom
of religion to somebody who's on the
verge of starvation.
So I,
it's not entirely satisfying
in that sense that,
that if a justifies saying,
well,
we will protect the person at the bottom,
even though even though the probability
of that person turns out to be low
because of the grave risks
assumption, why then, uh,
this is very annoying.
Yeah,
why then would we we make it third,
but it's not a really a deep criticism of
roles in that you could just say, okay,
well we should have reordered his lexical
ranking and put this Iraq payment.
But anyway,
that that's not entirely satisfying.
And then the second thing he says that's
not entirely satisfying is he says he,
he's sort of sensitive to this,
this problem that you might get
absurdities out of this because
mmm.
If it's,
if it's very costly to help the person
at the bottom in terms of what other
people have to give up,
um,
maybe,
you know,
maybe people wouldn't be that impressed
by the grave risks assumption.
So he throws in this idea
of chain connection and he
says, well, as a matter of,
even though,
even though my argument doesn't
depend on this, I'm gonna, I'm,
I think it's true. It's you. When
somebody does that, you know,
there's some slight of hand going
on and he basically says, well,
if you help the person at
the bottom that will help,
that will have some kind
of a chain we action,
it will help the person at the next
level and that'll help the person,
that next level and that'll
help the person the next level.
So it's a kind of Keynesian idea that
if you stimulate demand at the bottom,
they'll be multiplier effects
throughout the whole system.
That'll make everybody
else better off too. Well,
that may or may not be true.
And it also, by the way,
I think it makes the disagreement between
roles in ism and utilitarianism much
less interesting because then anything
that rolls would choose a utilitarian
would choose as well.
And we really want to look at when
they pull in opposite directions, if,
if we want to see what's
at stake between them. But,
so there's this chain connection idea.
I think it's just sort of,
he throws it in there to make
his art, his, his argument,
not more, uh, appealing on,
on consequentialist grounds,
but actually, um, it's not a no
reason to believe it's true. And B,
if it were,
then what's really at stake between roles
and utilitarianism becomes much less
interesting because by satisfying roles,
we're also going to be satisfying
utilitarianism. So I think,
uh, the best thing about chain connection
is to ignore it. So I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna say anything more,
but I will say this in, in, um,
enrolls his defense on this point,
which is a lot of people
have criticized roles create.
And I even did some of this myself
when I think I'm fair in retrospect,
people create
mmm.
Examples.
We're helping.
The person at the bottom comes at a
huge cost to others and it looks rather
implausible.
But one thing we should say about roles
is he's not trying to give policy advice
for every marginal choice.
At one point he says in the book,
I'm thinking about the basic structure
of society, the basic institutions.
So he's not saying, you
know, I mean, the example,
the example people sometimes
gave is the Reagan tax cuts.
Um, in the 1980. So actually
the, the Bush tax cut, uh,
in the,
in the two thousands,
but the Reagan one had this structure
more explicitly where there was a very big
tax cut for the wealthy,
the tiny tax cut for the
people at the very bottom,
and a huge increase in middle class taxes,
basically,
that this was the structure of it. And
people said, so roles would prefer this.
MMM.
And you know,
the answer is he,
he's not trying to make a
recommendation at the neck,
at the level of the next
incremental policy choice.
He's trying to say what the underlying
institutions should be structured as.
And so he, he would resist saying,
well, this shows my theory.
It's silly, or my theory
doesn't generate our, uh,
conclusions that I want it to
a, he, it's not a, it's not,
he's not a policy wonk.
Okay? He's saying this is,
he's thinking about constitutional
principles, basic principles,
the basic structure of
society. Um, and indeed,
I'll just make one footnote
to that footnote, which is,
mmm.
If you,
if you start at the front of a theory of
justice and you really plow through all
of it, uh, you get to about
page 300 and something,
and he says words to the effect that,
um,
his theory is agnostic between
capitalism and socialism.
Okay.
And he,
he took a lot of abuse for that in,
in the 1970s and 1980s
people's, you know, I say, wow,
you may not plow through 300
pages of a book about justice.
I don't need to be told it's agnostic
between capitalism and socialism.
Gimme a break.
Uh,
but in defense of rolls on
that point, he would say, look,
okay,
what economic system actually operates
in the interest of the least advantaged?
That's an empirical question of political
economy, trial and error and so on.
That is not a question for
political philosophy to settle.
I don't know whether it's capitalism,
socialism,
some version of a mixed economy,
um,
that works to the greatest benefit of the
least advantaged person that's for the
policymakers in political economist to
figure out what I'm telling you is what
the standards should be.
And so I think that that is a,
and that is a good argument
on roles as part of this.
And he's saying this is
what the standard should be.
The standard should be that whatever
system you have works to the greatest
benefit of, of the least advantage play
at when compared with other systems.
And yes,
you know,
yeah.
Before the experience of centrally planned
economies, people may have thought,
uh,
some version of state socialism would do
that after half a century of experience
with it doesn't look so good.
So we'll go back to some
kind of market system, uh,
and after,
you know,
decades of experience with unregulated
markets or minimally regulated markets,
and we discovered the costs of
those for the people at the bottom,
maybe we'll end up with something else.
So it's not a failing of my John Rolls,
his theory that I don't tell you what
kind of, uh, economic system to have.
My aspiration is to tell you what the
normative criterion is that it should
meet. Okay. So that's the,
that I think that's the,
the most important takeaway point.
Now
let's give you a picture
for those who like pictures. And
for those who don't, we will,
we will explain it in words.
This is,
this has gone back to our
paredo style of diagram.
Let's suppose that the status quo,
okay.
And now we've got primary goods in this
case and Commonwealth for two people,
a IPN be along here. And that's
the, that is the district.
That is the status quo.
So Aa has more than B.
Okay.
Roles is difference principle or the
so called maximin principle of welfare
economics says rob up line down to that.
That's point is perfect quality.
Right?
And then go east
and everything in this shaded area.
Yeah.
Is What we might call roll
superior to the status quo.
So is it kind of l shaped
indifference curve, right.
Because down through the status quo
to equality and then it turns right.
Anyone want to
take a stab at telling us why?
Why would you have these l shaped him?
Difference curves.
Yeah. Why didn't you get the
mine? Uh, cool. Come to them.
Okay.
You can move right as far as possible.
And that will be increasing the goods
for B and then as you move down you have
to stop at the quantity.
Okay. But why I'm, why say a has
this, my tried when we start out,
why would it,
why,
why isn't this points here that
I'm lighting up say roles preferred
because then a becomes the least
advantaged person and they have less than
exactly right. You got
it. So the reason we turn,
we'd go head east or turn right at the
point of equality is what are we trying
to do in Matt?
We maximizing the minimum share with
saying the person will only want to say is
that whoever turns out to be at the
bottom has the highest possible share.
So if we went from x to down here,
then then we would have changed who at
the bottom. And that's not important.
What would be important is that the,
this bottom share would be
smaller and we wouldn't want that.
So we don't care who gets it because
we don't know whether we're a or B.
That's not material,
right? We had done our way,
the one that when the veil of
ignorance turns out to be lifted,
we don't know where that
we're going to be a or B.
So we just gonna assume we're going to
be whoever turns out to be the worst off.
Okay,
so this is,
this distance here represents the
minimum and you wouldn't want it to get
smaller basically.
Okay.
So if we moved anywhere in this area here,
the minimum share would get
bigger. So if we went to y, right,
then we could do a new l
shaped indifference curve.
Why is it doing this
much later?
Why isn't there a restart
much later button?
Okay, so, so that's the basic
idea. You, you just get the,
keep getting these al shape
indifference curves. Okay.
Now
I want to say something about what a
radical idea this is in a philosophical
sense.
It's not necessarily that radically in
the distributed of sense for the reason
I've already indicated to you.
It could be compatible with,
um,
trickled down if we took the view that
trickle down works better than any other
system from the point of view of the
least demand cottage. So we might say,
if you think about, let's put the,
the,
this role's Bentham and Paredo compared,
this is a lobe taking something of a
liberty because we've got different things
on the axes. So it's sort of a
little, ultimately not coherent,
but I think you can still get an
insight out of it if we, if we, uh,
start with that status quo. We
know watch Paredo preferred, right?
So everything that's Pereda preferred
is also rolls preferred, right?
So if it turned out to be true,
that the best way to help the
person at the bottom is to have,
um, only the market trend, you know, uh,
market transactions,
then we would do it. Um,
but if it turned out that there was other
ways that we're parade out undecidable
like these, um, to help
the person that bottom,
we would do that.
Okay.
So it's not necessarily radical
in a distributive sense.
You could get very egalitarian,
radical redistribution,
but you could also get, uh, a diff, you,
you could get no redistribution and
could get the parade, oh, system.
If that turned out to be the way in which
the most disadvantaged person is help
the most.
Um,
but it's radical in a philosophical sense
that I think is captured by the fact
that it, by the observation
that we don't care whether it,
whether we turn out to be gay or
whether we turn out to B, two, B, B,
two, B, B. Um, and that is
the following.
Okay.
There's been a huge debate
in our lifetimes over whether
the differences between
us are the result of nature
or nurture right now.
Enormous debate. You read, you know,
you read a book like calm
Charles Murray losing ground.
How many people I've heard of that club?
Nobody. Wow. Uh,
quickly, things change. Well, it was a,
it was a book that came out
about probably 20 years ago.
That's probably why you haven't read it.
Uh,
basically saying that the differences
are between us are genetically determined
that genetic differences in Iq,
uh,
that show up in, uh, various
ways includes including racially.
And it was a huge storm of criticism.
He was accused of being a racist,
uh,
and there was charges and counter
charges. Um, and people said, no,
it's not genetics,
it's environment and so on.
So one of the most important things,
and I'm going to focus on
this much more next Monday,
I just want to mention it now
so you can think about it.
One of the,
one of the points roles makes his look
possibly differences between us,
our genetic,
okay.
If the differences between us
such genetic, it just moral luck,
right?
Because you didn't choose to have the
genes that you have and not only didn't
you choose it,
you didn't do anything to get the jeans.
God,
it's moral luck.
On the other hand, suppose differences
between us, our environmental,
well,
it's moral luck.
You didn't choose to be born in the
country and the family you were born into.
You didn't make any choices
in that regard. Furthermore,
you didn't do any work to be
in the
family or the country, country
or the family you happened
to have been raised in.
Again, it's just luck from your point
of view. It's a completely random thing.
You could have been born
somewhere else to somebody else.
So you could have been born to parents
who didn't have the resources that your
parents have.
So this whole debate about nature and
nurture says John Rawls is beside the
point from the standpoint of justice.
We don't care.
And that is his argument. I
think for what it's worth,
the most important argument enrolls a
spot that the differences between us are
morally arbitrary, whether it's
nature or nurture, it doesn't matter.
They're not the result of choice and
they're not really result of work.
They had just fell out of the sky
as far as were actually concerned.
That being the case,
I'm going to,
I'm going to go into the assumptions
behind that in more detail on Monday,
but from the point of view
of this discussion, so we
don't really care if a or B
is the worst off person.
We're just going to say from
the standpoint of justice,
we want to improve the lot
of the worst off person.
And even if the worst off person changes,
you know,
so we go from x, you know, two, two g,
okay.
It's morally irrelevant.
All we want to do is maximize the
share of the person at the bottom.
So that's the roles in
difference principle.
And
as I said,
you can see it,
it overlaps and contained with
and contains the predo principle.
And this has some overlap with Bentham,
uh,
in that it would sanction
moving into the parade. Oh,
undecidable zone here.
That might would be Bentham preferred
if it works for the greatest benefit of
the least advantaged person
and rolls his claim to you.
The reader is,
this is the principle you would choose.
You would want the economic system that
works to the benefit of the person at
the bottom.
What do you think?
Who likes this idea? Who
doesn't like it? What's,
what don't you like about
who was it was, yeah. Yeah.
Uh, it, it assumes that,
uh, once you're born,
you're going to stay in that
position for the rest of your life.
There's nothing you can do about it.
Ah, okay. That, well,
that's a good observation.
I'm not entirely sure what you saying.
Just just explain a little bit more and
I'll see if he was saying what I think,
what about effort that people put
into changing their social position.
Okay. What about effort? I
thought you were making another,
so let me just respond to the
point I thought you were making,
which you weren't making, but we
should nonetheless address, uh,
since people do sometimes make it,
but then I'll come to your point,
which is in any way much more interesting.
The,
the point I thought you were making
is this has no dynamic side to it.
That is to say, um, it's, it's,
it's static and exactly the way
the predo principle is static.
But in any economist would want a theory
that has a dynamic dimension to what
you would want to know over time.
What's the effect of a certain
redistributive change. Uh,
and that, so we would, we
would want to say, you know,
mmm,
we would want to say,
well,
if benefiting the person at
the bottom slightly improves,
improves their welfare,
uh,
in the next three months.
But it comes at the cost of lower
economic growth over time. Would we want,
would we want to do that?
Okay.
And it's fair to say roles doesn't
have an answer to that question.
He doesn't have a dynamic theory. On
the other hand, I think his defense,
this is why it's ultimately not
a very interesting criticism.
I think his defense would kick in that
while I'm telling you what the criteria
and should be,
not how to run the economy.
But let's come to the point about fn
and this has got to to some degree Greek
get us into a next Monday's lecture.
But it's good to make it a start at it
cause it's a very deep point actually.
What about effort?
So yes,
the capacities we have might be
distributed in morally arbitrary ways,
but
some people choose to work really hard
and some people choose to sit on the
couch and watch ESPN all day.
Yeah.
Right. And let's suppose you have
two people with exactly the same Iq,
but one watches ESPN all
day and one studies hard.
So the one who studies hard gets the a
and the one who watches ESPN all day gets
to see and
okay.
I take the input of what you saying. Well
there's some legitimate dessert there.
The person who works should
get the AA. Yeah. Okay.
Now roles sort of with you,
but in a way that I don't think works
for him because if you read Rawls
carefully,
what he says is exactly what you'd said.
He says this, yes, the differences
between us, I'm morally arbitrary,
but
the use we choose to make
of our capacities is not,
why doesn't it work for him?
This was sorta like bent them being
scared of the egalitarian implications of
his theory.
And so he wheels out the difference
between absolute and practical equality of
it hasn't really worked for him
either. What reasons? He said,
why doesn't this really worked for roles?
Yeah,
me,
sorry,
could you say that it's someone's
like naturally, you know,
just by luck given a capacity
or a predilection to work hard.
So that's exactly that. The where
I, I was hoping you would go that
well.
Some people have a
supercharged work ethic
and some people don't.
And why do some people have a supercharged
work ethic because of the way they
were raised? Perhaps. Maybe
some of it's genetic paps,
but why isn't that
morally arbitrary as well?
If the differences in Iq
are morally arbitrary?
So weakness of the well
weakness of the,
well no morally arbitrary too
or strengthened the, well, it's
morally arbitrary. So you know,
the,
the person who sits on the couch watching
ESPN all day just doesn't have the
same,
he doesn't have the moral luck to
have a lot of Protestant work ethic.
So he should,
shouldn't be penalized for that.
So now you can see why roles
doesn't want to go there.
Right?
Because it has the effect of completely
obliterating the concept of any personal
responsibility.
Okay.
Right. Ultimately, because
once you make that move,
why should you differentiate between the,
the weakness of the well or the strength
of the well and say that's not morally
arbitrary,
but differences in Iq are more
morally arbitrary or athletic ability.
RMR morally arbitrary. It
doesn't seem to work. Right.
So it's,
it's not as satisfying way out for roles.
And he does it because he's afraid of
the radical implications of this view.
But what's,
what's interesting about this,
you know, Rawls is fixed, doesn't work,
but he's underlying arguments are
very powerful argument. I mean,
isn't it right? It, isn't it just true
that you know,
the differences between us nature
or nurture are morally arbitrary.
They all, it is moral luck whether
it's genetics, so upbringing,
nothing. You did nothing.
You chose nothing.
You have therefore any
particular right to.
So you know,
you guys think you all worked so hard
to get into Yale and all this and you
deserve to be here.
It's allowed of bug not have.
You deserve to be here
more than anybody else.
That's what he's saying.
You know,
it might be a nice fiction you're telling
yourself, but you know, and his uh,
you know,
as this little exchange showed his
attempt to put some limits on his ideas,
just pathetic. It doesn't
work. But the basic,
the basic argument about
moral arbitrariness,
it's totally compelling.
Anyone here think it's,
it's not compelling and I don't
think it's a good argument.
I don't think it's compelling
because it has implications.
I don't want to live with.
MMM.
B You have to have some other reason.
I mean, it may, well, I think it does.
Let me say this.
I think it has implications that
if you really drill down into them,
probably nobody in this room wants to
live with just like John Rawls didn't want
to live with them,
but what's a good way out?
Okay.
Who thinks I'm wrong?
Who thinks this is a bad argument?
It just not a good argument.
Nobody.
Yeah.
Yeah. Well not that I disagree,
but it seems to strip down
human freewill in that,
um, if the only condition which manages
the circumstances of your birth,
then you don't really have any
choice as to the course of your life.
Um, so it seems, it seems
completely deterministic,
which might not.
Yes and no. It's not it. I think it's
agnostic on the question of freewill.
He's not saying we don't have free,
well, maybe we do. Maybe we done.
I think what he's saying is
if some of us have a greater
say to work hard or to,
you know, engage in delayed
gratification than others,
that is a difference between us. You
know, just as an empirical matter.
That is a difference between us.
MMM.
But the person who has what he's saying
is that the person who has the greater
capacity for deferred gratification or
the greater capacity to work hard isn't
entitled to more benefits than the person
who doesn't happen just in virtue of
that strong strength of the
will. So He's, he's not saying,
I mean, it might also be true
that we don't have free will,
that's another matter.
But I think he's just not taking
a position on that question. So,
um, in that, you know, I,
I think in that sense,
I mean, he, he, he, he,
you could, you could do a two by two in
Philly and all the boxes. He's, he's not,
he's not saying we don't have,
well, we, we, we can't make choices.
He's just saying
the choices that we
make don't give us any,
any particular rights. Now,
I mean, I, I think one is,
and maybe what you're getting at that is,
does pin the tail on the donkey. Is
he what he, what he's saying is, um,
ultimately subversive of the idea
of individual responsibility.
But that's not the same thing
as determinism. You know, when,
when did they come together
and other settings.
So if somebody says, uh,
while I committed the murder,
but I was in the grip of,
of uh,
schizophrenia disorder and
so I didn't have free, well,
so I'm not responsible because
I did, you know, that's when,
uh,
determinism and the issue
of the welcome together,
but he's not making that kind of argument.
He's conceding I think for the purposes
of discussion that the risk free.
Well,
but just saying,
I'm s I'm saying when
you take away his fix,
which really I don't think it does work.
You're saying that differences that flow
from our strengths of well should an
entitle us to anything in particular.
So none of you deserve all the good
things you've gotten in life just because
you work hard. So why, if you work hard,
you have the capacity to work hard.
I let people did it.
So
anyone think it's just
not a good argument?
Anyone think? Seems like a good
argument, but you really don't like it.
At least some who really likes it.
The people I want to go
and watch ESPN all day.
MMM.
You know, and they're,
they're philosophers who
followed the same tuition.
There's a guy called Phillip Perez,
a Belgian political thinker. Yeah.
What were you going to say?
Yeah.
Um, is this, uh,
is this an argument in favor of
complete equality then in terms of
redistribution? Okay, so
that's a good question.
I'll leave Philly out of it.
Cause your question's more important,
not when he has to say, um, is this, uh,
an argument for equality roles?
His answer is a qualified yes.
He's saying it's not an
argument for equality.
It's an argument for the
difference principle.
He's saying it's an argument
for distributing things
in such a way that they
benefit the part,
the person,
the bottom.
Now
you have to have a whole theory of
how the political economy works to say
whether redistribution toward, to absolute
equality would do that. Because if,
if redistribution to equality would
destroy incentives, let's say.
And so that over time, you
know, this would go this way,
um, then it wouldn't be
right. Um, but he's so,
so it's, it's an, he would say we,
what it's an argument for is,
is detaching what we get from
any theory that it's ours as,
as some kind of moral,
right?
And connecting it to what
some theory that the,
the best going theory of the day about
how you organize an economy to benefit
the person at the bottom.
That's what you should do.
If [inaudible] quality does that, you
have a qual. If the market does that,
you have the market,
but it's not anything else.
It's just as pure consequentialist plane
do it in order to help the person at
the bottom.
So Fun paresis point, Phillipe,
fond paresis boy, he says,
while he wrote a book called Real
Freedom for all, and he said, yes,
everybody should get
a minimum basic income
and it shouldn't have anything to do
with their work, their capacity to work.
So, and the famous one liner, he
says, even surface should get pet.
Even surfers should get
paid. We should, uh,
h s s e s fond parades puts it.
There should be the highest sustainable
universal basic income, whatever that is.
And it shouldn't be connected
to work because you know,
capacity to work is morally arbitrary.
So what I'm going to talk about
on Mondays, I'm going to come,
we're going to really dig into this
question because you can now see, I mean,
one of the ironies I want you to
mull over between now and then,
one of the ironies is that this puts
rolls white to the left of marks in a
certain sense because as we
saw marks was as straight up,
uh,
enlightenment theorist wedded to the
whole workmanship idea. Remember,
lock workmanship, labor theory
of value, all that stuff, right?
The Marxist critique of
capitalism was the work.
I doesn't get what he produces.
Rawls is saying,
we don't care in any moral sense.
We don't care who did the work
because the capacity for work isn't,
uh,
capacity that brings with it any
particular moral valence because
of this moral arbitrariness argument.
Okay?
We will pick up from there next week.